Gangnam bcn 1 There is level 5
i'm last name we are nl evein slang this
isaon sol
uh um
I wanted to learn video art, so I went to a lecture, and the teacher there
was Mr. Lee Seok.
When I first met Danbi, it felt like spring was coming.
It came to me like spring melts the earth
I had to work, I have to make a work,
so I named the art work together.
I was planning to go to New York for a
movie. My
brother has to continue promoting in Korea, so we are separated from each other countless times.
When I came to the plan, it was sad to be apart
I wandered around looking for similar things in the area of a cafe or project, we started with the desire to be together  It seems
that we have trust and dependence on each other and we
were able to share our emotions Dramatically show the spirit of love that transcends the limits of time and space Do
you mean that we can meet again that we are apart It's
sad, but in Seoul, but we hear the direction of all our lives
Come, work becomes life,
it's new, it's already my sister,
my name is my dream, my dream, my birch, my logic and me, it's so good,
we love the theme of Australia and keep playing the ball no matter what